so there's this viral tweet going around
from a Tumblr account from a person
named Zan who is a trans man detailing
the culture shock he's experienced
post-transition it was really
eye-opening and interesting to hear that
he has been perfectly positioned to gain
insight into unique gender Dynamics and
social conditioning so I'm just going to
straight up read most of Zan's post to
you because I thought it was incredibly
perceptive and I want to amplify it but
I don't want to risk messing up his
words or his message so here we go I'm
pretty quiet about the fact that I'm a
trans man but holy [ __ ] what did you
have to put the mustache on well you
know there are trans men who don't wear
mustaches right but
I don't know it's just to me it just
seems very gender normative to do the
impression of a trans man you've never
seen or heard and then assumed that they
would have a mustache but whatever if
you call that inclusivity good for you
girl oppressive ass [ __ ]
sorry I'm not gonna lie man you know
what it feels good being like a good a
canceling sjw it feels good yeah
I see why they do it yeah I want to be a
jackass yeah you remember there's this
huge sense of social isolation that
comes with being perceived as male
because now people are subconsciously
treating me as a potential Predator all
strangers no matter their gender keep
their guard up around me it made me
realize that there was no inherent
camaraderie in male socialization like
there is in female socialization unless
of course it's in very specific
environments and the fact that I don't
ambiently experience this Mutual kinship
in basic exchanges anymore is an
insanely lonely feeling you know how bad
this would have [ __ ] up my mind if I
had grown up like this it is 4 30 a.m
and I I'm mourning the loss of a
privilege I didn't know I had yes yes
welcome
yeah put it there one of us one of us
one of us
to summarize a woman becomes a man to
realize it's hard
and I talk about the dick you feel me
it's just difficult yeah uh uh you're a
CIS smell yeah shit's hard I am
just [ __ ] it's not easy it's just
that we make it look easy
I mean
mommy this is not easy she's talking
about like everyone sees you as a
predator I know yeah listen sometimes
I'll just be walking home late at night
and a [ __ ] will be in front of me and I
know she's scared I'm like I ain't
trying to touch you like but you acting
terrified so now I gotta Watch How I I
didn't do nothing I want to go home
masturbate but she's over there
trembling like I'm about to jump her
from behind I just existed and she's a I
understand why I went across a girl in
his cheek and across a girl she's right
there I'm right walking my line right
she's walking on the line I'm walking my
line if she looks away I gotta look away
just to show her that I am I'm not
interested I am not trying to make a
move boo-boo I'm not going bad you know
I mean so I have to walk and look away
if she looks at me if she looks at me
and we cross eyes and she smiles I gotta
smile look down and look away for her to
keep on going knowing that she just when
she's you don't want to do that you know
why people they see my be willing to go
like
you know that
that
across the girl she does
I just move on
yeah and I have this [ __ ] but it is
I used to think women liked animals so
when I would walk by myself
[ __ ] doesn't work when it comes from a
man I don't it don't work when it comes
from me
I'm just saying you don't like me listen
I I don't even go to Parks so I could I
don't want kids around I don't want
nobody if I see there's a meme no in a
TV show
thank you
[Music]
I'm clothing I'm clothing now keep the
kid away from me oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're not doing that he wants
okay I'm gonna tell you guys a step up
okay this is something that you want to
know how deep this [ __ ] goes this is
something that I know it's true that's
[ __ ] up that even you watching you
would say oh yeah I think that way as
well okay women and men watch it right
now this is something that you think any
of you [ __ ] have kids great you
go to a daycare and there's a man
working there you get suspicious
in fact most women I know have openly
admitted that they would not leave their
kids in a daycare with a man here's
where it gets worse men also share that
sentiment
Now understand what this means a man has
simply existed
done what they'd like and assumed to be
a printer in fact there's plenty of
daycares that will not hire men for that
very same reason this is not an
exaggeration you can do through Google
searches okay men will tell you
it's very difficult for them to teach
young children learning this stuff
because they get asked weird questions
or there's a heightened sense of
security around them now look I'm not
here to come after the parents I
understand as a parent that's your seed
you want to protect them you're like
crazy about protecting them but I also
want to appreciate it's not fair that I
just simply exist in the world and I'm
immediately but that's what it is but
there's nothing we're going to do about
it that's it I don't piss and moan I
don't cry about it but it's the fact
it's a fact a girl seeing a kid oh oh
your kid is very beautiful mean thing
again your kid is cool
I ain't saying nobody beautiful that
little [ __ ] ain't beautiful
frankly this is something I would have
never understood without living the
experience it is now blatantly clear to
me that most CIS men probably experience
chronic emotional malnutrition they're
deprived of social connection just
enough for it to seriously [ __ ] with
their psyches but not enough for them to
realize that it's happening and what's
causing it it's like they're starving
okay okay okay stop you're using your
standards as a woman and assuming that
because we don't have the same lived
experience as you that therefore we are
[ __ ] up or something terrible is
happening to us what we are built
different
we have different needs now while there
is a lot of overlap between men and
women it's not because we don't go
through the exact same experience as you
that it's inherently making us
malnourished or whatever
all right the same way that trans woman
who became a trans man isn't a man
not in the way that CIS men are she
doesn't have our lived experience of
having lived as a young boy and a young
man in their entire life so she's got
her own or she's got his own experience
you get what I'm trying to say and we
cannot deny that because he's denied a
whole experience it would be like saying
I don't see color no you're denying all
the experiences that person is living
I can't understand what it's like to be
a trans man I can't imagine what it's
like to have been born a female okay and
then gone through your whole life well a
sizable portion of your life as a woman
and then transition and all those things
the same way the trans trans man can't
understand what it's like growing up as
a young man and then growing into that
you don't understand it's like they're
starving but they don't know this
because they've always been served three
meals except those meals have never been
big enough this deprivation comes from
all sides of the aisle by the way in the
case of women when I'm out in public and
interact with them all of them come off
as incredibly aloof cold and mirthless I
have never experienced this before even
though I know exactly what this
composure is the armor that keeps away
creepy ass men as someone who used to
wear this myself I know that this armor
is a hundred percent impersonal nobody
likes wearing it and I can say with
absolute certainty that women would dump
the armor in favor of unconditional
companionship with men if doing this
didn't run the risk of actual assault
trust me when I say that women aren't
just being needlessly guarded but I only
have complete understanding of this
context because I've experienced female
socialization if I hadn't I would have
thought this coldness was a conspiracy
against me devised by roughly half the
human population even now with all I
know about navigating the world as a
woman I am failing to convince my monkey
brain that this armor is not social
rejection and as for male socialization
again it seems taboo for a man to be
platonically intimate with men for
reasons I have yet to fully understand
but I think it boils down to a the fact
that Society teaches boys that it's not
okay to be soft with each other and B
Garden variety homophobia our media only
shows men being intimate with one
another when they're teamed up against a
dire situation yo listen
[Music]
Garden variety homophobia so the reason
why I'm not touchy feely with my homies
is because I don't like or I have some
internalized fear of like
that's gay hey let me ask you do you
ever have temptations or do you ever
have like a desire to have a dude hug
you
[ __ ] this in my life not even some I've
thought about [ __ ] I thought about
murder I thought about throwing things
off off of buildings people off building
I thought about a lot of stuff you know
I have what because my imagination will
go everywhere and a bunch of people
write this down like I was a murderer
and waiting no calm the [ __ ] down we all
have extreme crazy thoughts
I've literally never thought of like yo
why won't my [ __ ] hug me no not the
white with my [ __ ] hug me but yeah
sometimes I see my [ __ ] and I'm
like yo you good I'm good all right man
we have a long talk and everything is
all good and some you know we have a
long time a long talk they open up and
like yo put it there man we good all
right yeah yeah but I'm not gonna be
like
he didn't hug me today no that doesn't
happen like that that no that's not what
it is but sometimes you see your friends
you know
we how can I put this this way so you
can understand really simply we
are not women
but the reason why you're not women is
because of culture and the way that the
shut that [ __ ] up oh okay so the reason
that we we we we show look do you know
what you can't even understand I don't
think even you saying that you don't
even understand why between man this
does watch yo what's good oh yeah this
this is different a good one a good good
yeah
how intensely you do it is generally an
indication of how like close you are how
long you haven't seen them or whatever
it might be like when you ain't seeing
your people in a long time you make sure
it's extra to relate to them that you're
that happy so it's not that we don't
have that kind of food we just reserve
it for special times or we when we need
it we have different ways of doing it
too and it's not like it's something
that we're lacking I've never thought to
myself like all my days I'm in need of
physical intimacy from my it's not what
I look for okay let me break it down for
you all right there's a couple of things
that we do all right b games you know
some sometimes
you look so good today we we just like
yo
this is you right there yeah [ __ ] it is
you and when we when we give us it works
give me your hand your hand we're gonna
just point out a [ __ ] while we
give that Hitler it's you no it's you I
I never done that before no but some of
us do all right there's some levels in
this [ __ ] it's like yo yo I see you I
see you you understand and it's quick
quick but we're not We're not gonna stay
on that [ __ ] no no but that that the
handshake yeah I hope have you seen
basketball players with the whole
intricate handshake that means something
it's a history it's a recall and a
recollection of all the the Insight
jokes they have together they put in the
handshake to say remember this remember
this remember this remember this yeah I
feel you all right I'm happy to see you
it says all that
all that but trust this and how loud it
is that's a that's a hug you're probably
never gonna understand that because
that's not what you'll be doing with
your homies I ain't never done that to a
girl
ever I have because for my friends are
studs
Hey listen just because they like
cosplaying as dudes you know I mean
don't mean you need to treat them like
yeah yeah
all right give them give them a good hug
absolutely right but it is but it is
what it is so there's something that
you're not gonna understand and I bet
real money it's a huge ass reason why
men gravitate towards activities that
simulate being teamed up against an
opposing Force but men are not Machines
of War yeah testosterone absolutely
gives you dumb bastard brain but that
just makes you want to like skateboard a
wagon down a hill or duct tape your
friend to the wall not kill someone
the human species looks so much colder
standing from this side I can see how
men might convince themselves that their
feelings of emotional desperation is
personal weakness as opposed to a
symptom they're experiencing from White
imperialism white imperialism so you
wait you think that the reason why men
are stoic all over the world is because
a white imperialism white people what
the ah hold up let me let me be fair to
Anna here she's reading what this person
wrote however she says that it echoes
things that she finds are very
interesting or if she's not pushing back
on is she still reading that she's still
reading it but she's not pushing back on
I'm assume that she tacitly agrees but
I'm not gonna come for it what I'm going
to say is why why
listen this kind of stowed Behavior
exists all over the world and in a lot
of different factions there's a lot of
different reasons but generally it's
because
one of the reasons and probably one of
the primary reasons because when you're
the primary Breadwinner when you're the
one who puts food on the table for your
entire family especially in places where
life is tough you don't have the luxury
or the time or the space to constantly
be emotionally open you've got [ __ ] that
needs to get done
my mom wasn't the most emotionally
person or open person why because she
was so busy doing this and doing that
and working like crazy it wasn't an
opening available to her you know what
I'm trying to say now if you want to say
we are now in a place now where people
don't have to struggle as much so there
can be a little bit I think that meant
today are far more open emotionally than
they've ever been before amen
it takes time there's an adjustment
period but it doesn't mean that the
whole process is suffering or anything
like that stoicism I'm not gonna lie
lady some of y'all can eat that some of
y'all need that some of y'all need to
learn to shut the [ __ ] up sometimes
because not everything that you feel
needs to be voiced the same way men
sometimes need to learn to open up a
little bit more
absolutely
seen progress we are not the same place
today that we were 20 30 years ago okay
and people speak about this character
I'll just finish this character like men
who never show them listen dudes don't
watch a dude cry on television they'll
see a dude cry during a moment and they
won't just be like what a [ __ ] loser
no generally they're very accepting and
open of it just recently we covered a
video of a dude getting a call from his
mom because you see something then he
starts breaking out crying nobody
thought that [ __ ] was lame or weird
right so that's the advancements a lot
of people are not a man a lot of men in
the comments were saying I shed a tear
with him
I share the theory with them because the
human condition is as essential for our
well-being as water is so sick how sick
I want to destroy this garbage end quote
and well right just wow you know I have
been in a place where I'm really trying
to unpack a lot of things that have been
taught to me that don't serve me and
that may be pretty outdated like you
know Pluto isn't a planet anymore or
Neanderthal is pronounced Neanderthal so
maybe the foundational knowledge I have
about more important things like gender
Dynamics maybe the things that were
taught to me when I was Tiny
impressionable clay just aren't valid
anymore and look even saying like female
privilege makes me want to recoil but I
like that I'm really aware of how much I
am rejecting that phrase and idea
because when I listen to the words of
Zan who has crossed the gender divide I
agree like having close intimate high
quality friendships is an absolute
privilege and I can see now how my
gender sets me up in Western Society to
have that you know I'm a baby queer and
I think we're learning all the time
hopefully we're learning all the time
how to unpack the biases and falsehoods
that we've been given by a generation
that's baby queer
why are you asking me
I feel like you're the one who's got the
plug to the lgbtq company so I'm asking
you because generally I do but I'm not
in on all the secrets okay and maybe
baby queer is something that she made up
I'm not gonna google it so y'all can let
me know I'm just not not now listen
I did pansexual I did demisexual and
demisexual was the last one bro
baby queer
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay let's not baby queer sounds
yes yes yes it sounds like child
presentation yeah yeah it sounds like
something that should be illegal
all right let's carry on oh that's a
baby Queen
I'm sorry bro sorry get your ass off of
Epstein Island right now all right this
Channel about to end those words are
never to be uttered again
I'm not going down with this [ __ ] you
Cast Away by your own Wilson all right
let's keep playing you know it takes
work for us to look at why we think what
we think and more importantly how do we
dismantle it and I can't count the
amount of times I've made like stupid
jokes about how men are trash I could
definitely see you same mental trash
yeah yeah
and not so much a joke
and so some of the work I've been doing
specifically around gender is to just
intentionally and actively look at why
do I think that and and what is the male
experience whether it's just or not and
how am I contributing to the toxic
masculinity in that space how am I
making it unsafe for men to express
themselves emotionally and what am I
taking for granted as someone who is
female identifying and assigned at Birth
and all of this means like really taking
accountability for the ways in which we
move through the world consciously and
unconsciously and that is exactly what I
loved about Zan's post like yes okay
women are overwhelmingly the majority of
victims when it comes to sexual assault
and murder I'm not going to pretend
otherwise but outside of that really
extreme violence in what ways can I as
an individual take care of other human
beings regardless of how they identify
next time she gets cat calls she's like
hey what's up [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's how you can help them don't do
that don't do that if somebody's cat
calling you don't don't you know uh yeah
uh baby queer is really just when you
just no moving on moving on just came
out all right let's go and in what ways
can we work together to dismantle old
systems that are leaving half of the
population
incredibly lonely all right yeah she
does agree with everything okay I
watched enough to know she agrees
everything in person what did you what
did you think about this whole thing
my conclusion if you didn't know now you
know yeah if you didn't know now you
know and shout outs to youthan and yeah
if you didn't know now you know that you
know but it doesn't mean that we're
depraved in any kind of things or
whatever whatnot you know but you don't
know
oh oh something's wrong with y'all we
don't think so we know better
why because we're women and we live
better
okay
cool
it's a bit presumptuous that's all I'm
trying to say this assumption is a bit
much but hey maybe I'm wrong maybe
there's guys right now who really feel
like what she's describing and could use
a lot of physical intimacy and could use
like more of their male friends giving
them hugs and love and all that stuff
and that's you then congratulations you
get a chance to leave a comment
Enlighten us maybe we're unaware
marijuana probably but uh
probably not yeah this is
I've heard this kind of rhetoric before
it's not new for me no
essentially the problem is toxic
masculinity again and manifesting your
inability to hug your [ __ ] when you
look you know what I'm saying that's the
problem
because a toxic masculinity you don't
know how to open up to you
I just that's not my experience those
experience with a lot of the dudes I
know but again
maybe there's some people out there yeah
what do you guys think do you guys agree
or disagree want to hear from you let us
know anything you want to say
very queer
yo men are really trash and this guy's
having a Time